-Our first guest is
a Golden Globe winner
for his work on the
very popular series
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
The eighth, and final, season
airs Thursdays at 8:00 pm,
right here on NBC.
Here is Andy Samberg!
Andy!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ "Brooklyn Nine-Nine" theme
sting plays ]
Wow.
That's what I'm talking about.
[ Whistling ]
[ Laughing, clapping ]
Yeah.
Feels like a long time,
but you were just here
before the commercial break.
[ Laughter ]
You look good, bud.
-Fond memories, for sure, yeah.
How are ya?
-We had some great memories.
"Purple Rain," we should've got.
Hey, happy belated birthday.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Thank you.
Appreciate that.
Did you do anything to celebrate
or anything special?
-Well, I'm doing
a little bit of work,
but I had a fun time.
I celebrated on the weekend
with my family.
-Aw.
I saw you have a little girl.
-Yeah, my daughter's four
-Wow.
[ Awwing ]
and she was really excited
for my birthday.
She told me, first thing
on my birthday, you know, like,
"Do you think you would want
donuts for your birthday?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"Do you want donuts
[ Laughter ]
for my birthday?"
-That's where we're going.
-She was like, "I mean,
if you got donuts
and there was a unicorn donut,
would you want that?
[ Laughter ]
-Of course I want that.
-So, yeah.
I got her a unicorn donut
for my birthday.
[ Laughter ]
-Four years old.
What do you play for music
around the house
for a four-year-old?
-Mostly just like
Too Short, N.W.A.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, kids love, yeah.
New stuff, yeah.
Throw in some
Megan Thee Stallion.
[ Laughter ]
Like, you know, kid stuff.
Yeah, kid stuff. Cardi B.
Yeah, of course, kid stuff.
-Lot of that.
Lot of Korn.
[ Laughter ]
Do you think about that
when you're playing songs, now,
for your daughter
and you're like,
"That's not the best song
for you to be liking"?
-I mean, it's either that
or KIDZ BOP, right?
[ Laughter ]
-That's true.
I don't mind a good KIDZ BOP.
-I want to get just
instrumentals of everything
and then like see
what she freestyles over.
[ Laughter ]
-Start 'em young.
-I grew up --
I have older sisters
and I would listen
to all their music.
I feel like I was like seven
or eight when I was like
listening
to Eazy E's first album.
[ Laughter ]
And I think about that now
and I'm like, "Goddamn!"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"I probably shouldn't
have heard that!"
But, you know,
it worked out fine.
And they're good beats.
-I remember having that cassette
and like hiding it
like under my bed or something.
I didn't want like --
I was like,
"Oh, this is the filthiest thing
I've ever heard in my life."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, my parents,
we would play it in the car
and my parents would be like,
"I don't know,"
but they didn't make us stop.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not true at all.
-Well, my dad
didn't make us stop.
My mom would not have
let it happen.
-Yeah.
You got a bunch
of things going on,
but I want to talk to you
about you and John Mulaney
are going to be the new voices
of Chip 'n Dale
[ Cheering and applause ]
in the new "Chip 'n Dale" movie.
-Yeah.
-We love Mulaney.
How cool is that?
Now, voicing Dale,
pressure's on.
Do want to give us a taste,
maybe a debut,
of what the Dale voice
will be like?
-Yeah, well, it's a long
legacy, obviously,
with the "Rescue Rangers"
and my buddy Akiva
was directing,
that's how it all sort of
got started.
-Okay.
-I feel like
I was a little let down because,
when he asked me to do it,
I was like,
"Oh, I'm going to like work
on my chipmunk voice," you know?
So I was like at home like --
[ Squeakily ]
Blah blah blah blah.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Clapping ]
Yeah! That's fantastic!
[ Applause ]
That is great!
-But, then I started doing that
and he's like, "No!
Just do your voice.
What are you doing?"
[ Laughter ]
-So you're just doing you?
-Yeah, it's an interesting take.
[ Laughter ]
It's almost like
a Roger Rabbit sitch,
the new "Rescue Rangers."
-Oh!
-It's like two live
in the real world with people.
And so we're we're Chip 'n Dale
like the cartoon actors.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Dude, that's fantastic!
-It's going to be really fun.
Yeah.
-That's legendary, dude.
Congrats on that.
That's super fun.
-Thank you.
-I want to talk to you
about "Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
This is the eighth
and final season.
Congrats on the long run,
by the way.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Thank you.
-That's legit.
-Thanks.
It's legit. It's on Thursdays
at 8:00 here at NBC.
Did it get emotional,
those last couple episodes?
-Yeah, for sure.
I mean, you know,
eight years
of doing the same job,
you get really attached
to the people,
you feel like family and --
You know, it was basically
like a week-long
mental and emotional breakdown,
the last week, I would say.
-Yeah.
-♪ Arrest,
arrest, arrest, arrest ♪
♪ Arrest, arrest,
arrest, arrest ♪
♪ Arrest,
arrest, arrest, arrest ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Did you --
♪♪
Did you hear that as well?
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, are we in the Matrix?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey, would you know
if I'm having a heart attack?
[ Laughter ]
-That was a digital
heart attack.
[ Laughter ]
-One of us is a robot.
♪ Arrest, arrest,
arrest, arrest ♪
[ Laughter ]
Like Max Headroom.
-♪ Cardiac arrest,
arrest, arrest, arrest ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Cardiac arrest, arrest ♪
Alright. Wow, wow, wow.
-P-P-P-P-Pepsi.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Dude, classic
"Max Headroom" ref.
-Classic Headroom!
-That's so classic Headroom,
dude. I got it.
-Ironically, didn't have
a lot of headroom in his shot.
[ Laughter ]
It was a pretty tight frame.
-Yeah, it wasn't the maximum,
at least.
It was probably the minimum.
[ Laughter ]
It's like Min Headroom.
-Min Headroom!
That was the prequel.
[ Laughter ]
-That's correct.
I want to tell everyone
to tune in
and watch "Brooklyn Nine-Nine"
for this last season.
And I want
to congratulate you again.
Not only is it super funny,
but I also thought it was
such a positive show as well.
-Thanks.
-It always put me
in a great mood.
The whole cast, top to bottom,
everyone was great.
So congrats on that, buddy.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Andy Samberg
in "Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
Take a look.
-I'm initiating
Operation Trident.
-Cool, just like
the sugarless gum,
because we're going
to chew them up.
-No, like the famed weapon
of the sea,
forged by the Cyclops
for Poseidon himself.
The trident has three prongs,
like my approach.
-Not to interrupt, but Aquaman's
trident has five prongs.
-That's absurd.
The prefix tri- means "three."
What this Aquatic Man carries
is better termed a pentadactyl.
-No, it's a trident.
They call it that
in the original theatrical
release and the Snyder cut,
so you're 100% wrong
and everyone's laughing at you.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Everyone's laughing at you.
I don't know. Yeah.
-Snyder cut.
-Congrats on the success
of that.
Also, this is exciting --
I heard that you're
already working
on a brand-new show.
You're actually
on one of the sets now.
Can you tell us
about the new show?
-I can, yes.
It's a cooking competition show
called "Baking It,"
produced by our friend
Amy Poehler,
and I'm cohosting
with Maya Rudolph.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Are you kidding me?! Come on!
♪♪
Oh, my gosh!
I love you guys!
Holy moly!
Stay safe, you guys.
I love it.
Andy Samberg,
Amy Poehler, Maya Rudolph.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-[ Laughing ]
-Catch back-to-back episodes
of "Brooklyn Nine-Nine"
Thursdays at 8:00 pm on NBC.